salut tout le monde on aime les villes
artificielles qui pompe l'eau de toute
une région chère verdure donc las vegas
notation lieu de summer league quel
bilan on peut en faire des rookie des
sophomores qui me jouait cette summer
league de mise en dessous
la summer league on va se demander avec
ben et alan quels joueurs ont été mis
dans de bonnes conditions par leur
franchise comment ça peut se concrétiser
sur le développement de ses joueurs et
puis comment ça peut se concrétiser dans
la vraie vie un vrai league la saison
prochaine podcast en deux parties partie
1 sur 2 enregistrée aujourd'hui avec
donc ben et alan bonjour messieurs
bonjour alex saluer l'excellent retour
est-ce que c'était dur de regarder de la
summer league c'était compliqué
by moi j'adore personnellement je trouve
qu'il faut qu'il y ait un ratio
une brique par trois points absolument
irresponsables prix et je pense que le
ratio doré était respectée après gros
charlotte aux joies du haut quercy abdul
cadjee qui a fait la pire briques j'aie
jamais vu a surgi elle est passée en bas
à droite du panier est la même pas
toucher au filet comme moi hier sur le
plus grand
alan pareil de tête en résulter un petit
hameau un petit câlin pour l'ase ouais
enfin obs que si on regarde ça fait tous
les genres santé on les connaît
quasiment non les a étudiées on les a
vus donc moi j'adore je retrouve des
joueurs puis c'est surtout à chaque fois
chaque équipe confie la balle à un
joueur en se disant réservé à essayer de
développer on va voir si ça marche par
du temps ça marche pas mais à des petits
éclairs penser c'est toujours cool puis
alan parle souvent d'observer des joies
dans différents contextes et justement
vu que nous on connaît tous ces joueurs
là on les voit souvent au collège dans
des contextes où tout tourne autour
d'eux luiz qui sont la force dominante
dans la laque c'est vraiment très très
intéressant de voir de livres dans un
contexte où ils doivent s'intégrer un
effectif ouais et da et d'ailleurs c'est
ça qu'on va parler
dans ce podcast c'est à quel point le
fait de mettre un joueur dans d'autres
conditions peut lui faire développer
d'autres compétences et donc avoir une
influence sur son avenir dont on va
parler on va parler du hand outils de
cette sénart league le vrai mais pis je
veux dire guy santos donc
[Rires]
non on va parler de siegen murray mais
après mais d'abord on va parler des
golden state warriors
parce que au delà de la blague dit
santos ben il a fait une belle somme et
reliques sont black black black il a
fait une belle soirée il a montré ses
seins
savoir les clubs professionnels
ils ont montré beaucoup de skieurs et de
réalité donné beaucoup de raisons à
steve coll de l'intégrer dans l'effectif
et j'ai vu qu'il avait eu des des
compliments il ya pleins d'articles ici
au brésil sur une descente hausse des
qui bouge le petit doigt est où ils sont
fous et compliments de atkinson
on a peut-être trouvé quelqu'un au
deuxième tour dans des caisses d'azur
golden state social and bus dans leur
summer des garçons qui étaient à golden
state et puis après quand les celtics et
contre les spurs
en fait c'était marrant parce que
c'était le projet tuning h tous qu'ils
voulaient met en place dans la durance
est ce mardi ça a été très très dur mais
c'était voilà on donne le ballon à
cunningham qui on voit ce qui se passe
moody pas vraiment parce que moody est
déjà beaucoup plus dans un rôle
prédéfini je pense que tu es ndi
peut-être qu'ils vont essayer de
développer autre chose mais est plus
facilement intégrables je pense qu'avec
les départs qu'ils ont eu à froid d'ici
je pense que moody's va jouer je pense
un peu de l'année prochaine et que mika
c'était vraiment lui donne le ballon on
essaye de voir et c'est pas encore c'est
pas c'est pas encore ça mais encore ça
c'est très très vite mais moody's pas si
vous avez vu le match quand new york il
l'a fait carrément la moitié des points
de son équipe on va terminer avec 68
points et bien finie avec 34 mais oui
bah moody ça peut être une pièce de
rotation badel comme comines gala était
il va l'être l'année prochaine mais
c'est vrai que le projet coming à alan à
la base quand tu le draft à ses eaux
comme ça l'histoire de geely ghetto le
projet comme gars c'est pas d'être un
rôle player non non non ils ont ils ont
super bien masquer ses défauts et mis en
avant ses qualités ça son année rookie
est sûre saison régulière il le faisait
poser des écrans où l'effort vers le
cercle jouer jouer quatre et ils usent
et dribbler le moins possible parce que
c'était vraiment le gros tous vos soucis
il a été obligé de dribbler parce qu'il
voulait un peu le faire porter la balle
et c'est pas encore que je pense que et
c'est pas super super super roo encore
je pense que il va avoir une deuxième
année un peu similaire à sa première je
pense beaucoup jouent aussi en bas mais
il faut des jeunes quand ils restent
très jeune ça reste un joueur qui par
son physique peut déjà voir des terrains
nba en saison régulière
je pense à saumur et ligue 2 l'année
prochaine ces six là il a encore des
soucis banon et basile la joie on c'est
bon non plus puisque ça reste un risque
un aspect vraiment négatif de cette
summer league c'est tous les blessés qui
a eu
ben vu des vaches et de chars pour se
blesser et d'autres aussi de naviguer de
will et jada ellie fin d'été aux dégâts
qu'on attendait un petit peu quoi est ce
que ça vaut le coup ce qu'il ya un
bénéfice
c'est intéressant qu'on parle de
kunhinga parce que il ya vraiment pour
moi il y aura un bénéfice à le faire
jouer l'année prochaine selon lui a
demandé de le dominer en summer league
cette saison un peu comme la mine de
coming out trois possessions sur cadre
où ils prenaient une mauvaise décision
où il perdait son calme on l'a vu perdre
son calme énormément dans cette sur les
globes vu le body language de langouët
le langage corporel était dégueulasse et
oui il ya un intérêt jdir c'est une
question que tous les joueurs avaient
des blessures un cochon doit surtout
pour un joueur qui va être voire de
rotation l'année prochaine et qui va pas
qui jouera pas 30 minutes par match oui
je pense qu'un intérêt à l'égard des
shows compétitif il a alors demandé de
montrer quelque chose c'est un bon pour
les joueurs de 2e et 3e années comme ça
c'est un bon second espace pour leur
demander de se prouver on sentait alors
qu'est ce qui lui manque à djanet and
coming a pour passer ce cap ou je peux
tenir le ballon allait au moins une ou
deux possessions en sortie de banc je
peux créer d'un truc moi même
moi c'est le rôle de la navigation bon
moment parce que
la prise de décision elle effacée et
sera facilitée par les différences
athlétique qui va et qui va faire en
fait pourquoi j'ai donné vie à rennes en
parlera à dominer son verdict parce
qu'ils se créent tellement d' espace bar
à mort parce que c'est un freak
athlétique après c'est beaucoup plus
simple de faire des prises de décision
ce que tu gagnes quand il gérera la
navigation balle en main des écarts qui
va créer si lampre si elle cette
navigation bon moment et s'améliore
salut salle ouvrira beaucoup de choses
il ya le tire tout le monde dit le tir
mais en même temps
la mécanique à la nature est un peu
problématique on n'a jamais tous achetés
vraiment qu'une gueule comme un bon
shooteur donc je pense que c'est plus la
navigation balle en main lui permettra
de ce que le jeu sans ballon il alla jeu
dans pose d'écrans sur chartres l'après
là il a montré avec les avec les
warriors plus dans le jeu est
extrêmement espaces et des warriors ça
ça marchait c'est intéressant qui parle
de ça à l'âne parce que
justement le lieu le jeudi pourrait se
passer du tout des oies rieuses un an
sur les grillades c'était des crampes et
c'était sur la responsabilité était à
joe nathan coming à et beaucoup de
situer à lui qui ont des prix des hordes
équilibre cédé deux points hors
d'équilibré ministre en ciné je pense
que ça pour moi pour moi moi ça a été un
gros une grosse confirmation des mauvais
pressentiment que j'avais lui
je suis je suis a veille de vendre mes
dernières pas que je vais dans l'île
effectivement ce pays sting compliqué
peu de joueurs très efficace au tir et
donc la prime à la prise de décision
rapide
pour revenir rapidement
sur mon ami guy santos je trouve qu'il a
excellé laborde en mai selon m il y là
il ya vraiment excellé sur je reçois le
ballon je sais tout de suite si je drive
main droite main gauche l'ambidextrie
importante
et est ensuite allé chercher contact
voilà moi je pensais qu'il y avait moins
accepté de contact ce que je connaissais
pas trop le niveau physique de la ligue
brésilienne
en l'occurrence écoute ça a l'air
d'aller quoi donc voilà pour
physiquement physiquement parlant oui
physiquement parlant il la dureté ou
contacter la tonicité moi j'étais
impressionné par ce qu'il a demandé le
ballon soit il était très vocal sur le
terrain il place ses joueurs
veulent apprendre des mots
il a lancé des briques
contre avec les écoute il a plutôt bien
joué si tu regardes les sna taux global
a plutôt bien joué ouais mais toi quand
hynix il avait un match de merde et la
fin ils ont mis le troisième effectifs
sur le terrain
ça veut dire quelque chose
mais effectivement mcma clown qui a
chopé un contrat non garanti
1 an
parlons james beattie qui gagnent marais
je peux en parler de wiseman auront
aussi tu veux on peut passer tu veux qu
est ce qui a produit ce pas s'affoler
twitter dont
le stand by french contre les spurs
ouais il a mis il a mis et deux tirs il
met des paniers à trois points
bah écoute non mais en fait c'est ce que
j'écrivais sur twitter avec le conteur
il a annoncé d'un commerçant
il a protégé le cercle
plus ou moins bien mais ça allait
maintenant il doit progresser dans les
lectures second rideau encore à la
discipline corporelle faire moins de
fautes et et ce qui est intéressant
c'est le toucher mais ça l'a toujours
été mais là c'est bien il confirme qu'il
a le renne gnb est peut-être un truc
qu'on n'avait pas osé revu chez lui pour
un troisième année c'est ce que voulait
dire aux gens pour un troisième année
c'était temps comment ils soient
légitimes sur un terrain font face à
domme barlow j'aime bien d'hommes borloo
mais moi aussi j'aime bien de moi
enfin j'espère dans la p2a deuxième
partie qui gagnent murray donc qui qui
est plus vieux que james wyman et
mais qui a été lui-même des pics
et on a vu des choses
qu'on savait on a vu des choses un peu
nouvelle j'ai vu une stat passé
notamment la pris énormément pas
énormément mais beaucoup plus de tirs en
sortie de dribble que ce qui faisait à
ayo a
donc qu'est ce que ça implique sur son
utilisation en année un ben est ce que
tu penses que ça change quelque chose ce
que tu as revue tes prédictions al haouz
non je n'ai pas vu mes prédictions à la
hauteur parce que même si au prix dé
sort des poules tirs assortis dribble ça
a été quand même aventureuse sur une
bonne partie d'entre eux mêmes quand sa
rentrée c'est à dire que le derrière
surtout que lorsqu'il se dirige vers le
panier très haut et très très l'ange
donc le wiki ça a fonctionné en summer
league mais si on se s'attend à ce
qu'ils aient les mêmes le même niveau de
succès en ethnies je crois que
keegan mari au départ on l'achetait
comme un shooter un mouvement n'est pas
fait la même chose en mouvement qui est
dégradée ce projet je crois qu'on l'a vu
qu'ils étaient plus loin qu'on croyait
dans sa progression de ce côté là
défensivement aussi ça fait quand même
assez propre donc moi j'avais dit je
suis guéri fans des vikings se voulait
se défenestrer le soir de la draft mais
moi je leur ai dit il va être bon il va
ajouter de la valeur mais est ce que je
vois qu'ils vont tracter après tu as une
meilleur que lui potentiellement et je
me maintiens après cette performance de
son bolide jaune
il a alors c'était pas trop une question
mais quand même il l'a fait qu'une seule
saison ancien de haut volume et haute
efficacité au tir il confirme largement
sur ce qu'on a vu sur cette summer
league alan que franchement il est très
très solide au tir ça part vite sa part
haussé ses sorts voit clairement il a
même ajouté en fait à rio à c'était
vraiment le finisseur d'axoum ultime il
était vraiment pour ça qu'il était super
j'avais des supers bons pourcentages et
parce qu'ils étaient autant aimé par
parler de la communauté je pense
analytics parce qu'il a été ultra ultra
ultra efficace sur des sur des choses
simples là il a elle trouve qu'il a fait
des choses plus complexes en fait il a
posé un dribble sur un tacle de clausade
pour couler pas mi distance il a pris
les trois points alors ça ben daughdrill
coup échouant moment il faisait toujours
mais un joueur de sa taille qui prend
des styger en
remontant calme en face au panier qui
tire en mouvement et qu'il le fait aussi
bien
c'était impressionnant moi c'est par
contre la défense où j'ai été très
agréablement surpris et je pense qu'en
fait année après année en ce caillou à
des schémas les plus horribles on est
très défensivement c'est j'adore cette
équipe j'adore les regarder jouer année
après année mais espèce de zone qui font
un 3-1 les espèces de penser peut-être
pour cacher un manque un politique qui
sort pas mal de certains poissons
d'euros -10 et l'an dernier pendant
quand on parlait de luca garde
défensivement il peut tenir les 4 je
pense que peut il peut ne pas être
ridicule et c'est ce qu'on disait tout
ce soir de la draft je pense ça va être
un très bon joueur sur ça sera un très
bon joueur nba juste et honnête des
potentiels vous était là c'était le
grand débat est ce qu'on disait à ce
moment là mais il va être très solide
pour les pour les kings il va être
solide et
effectivement bonnes séquences
défensives et l'utilisation offensive
intelligente encore quand même un peu
félicité le l'à propos du staff des
kings ski on parlait des shoots après
mouvements etc ils ont mis en confiance
directes en début dé match il avait
souvent d'aider des systèmes pour lui
pourra avoir des tirs entre guillemets
ouvert le mettre en confiance et ensuite
commencé à ajouter après mouvement un
petit mot sur qui on élit ce peut-être
un désir
et canalis qui a fait une très bonne
entame et reliques pour l'équipe
cindy c'est potentiellement un tissu une
dizaine bien jouer honnêtement
on le disait tous mais c'était peut-être
le prospect d'alabama le moins hype
parce qu'ils étaient plus vieux et parce
qu'il venait plus de djoko avant et
qu'il a fait que deux années pic en plus
c'est un seul regret année puisque l'an
dernier sortait du banc
mais il est super celui de moi j'ai vu
le premier match contre miami je crois
que miami à la summer league de golden
state super sweet je pense que ça va
être un bon lorsqu'il va être dans
l'équipe de j-league parce qu'ils sont
profonds quand même sur les ailes à ces
postes là un peu mais je pense qu'il a
montré qu'il est un légitime en voyant
une bille en moment ci a besoin
tant mieux de ben
s'agirait pas de peser
non il ya montré il ya montré une belle
énergie je trouve s'il y en a un à
gandhi des choix actif en défense puis
il y aurait été capable de mettre de
laisser sa marque sur des matches
défensivement il faut bien shooté aussi
la match que j'avais ajouté cinq ans en
fait c'était très bien non moi j'ai eu
beaucoup et je ne pensais pas grand
chose a pas eu des opinions bien
tranchées ce qui en est lisse avant
j'étais petit mais
est ce qu'on passerait pas aux sujets
suivants qui sont les roquettes
cheikh al ain que tu as pas mal observé
jabbari
tahiti washington plus les joueurs
également les sophomores cache
christopher kane
n'a pas joué non stationné christopher
que tu les bouées de secours marque
qu'est ce que tu retiens déjà une leçon
cette
ligue des roquettes quelle utilisation
tu as bien aimé chez le joueur
moi j'ai car ils sont honnêtement c'est
a été tous ce que je pensais qu'ils
pourraient être vraiment au niveau
supérieur c'est-à-dire
comment un genre de ceux de sète avec
triton de physique qualité peut dominer
même s'il est encore brut dans beaucoup
de domaines juste par
l'athlète que c'est qu'il a été vraiment
impressionnant là dessus le tir est
encore en question l'a dit que la
mécanique un peu de catapult ce qui par
mais à la fin ça a été plutôt
intéressant finition proche du poignet
puis des forcément quand il le veut et
les élites taille washington va pas au
cercle il va toujours pas
mais ils à l'adresse midrange à
l'adresse flotteur qui fait que je pense
qu'il vivra tout servi sur détient un
peu complexe un peu un lit un trait yang
maxi format dans le couvent est
nécessaire c'est ça et puis son génie
créatif mais oui oui celui jabba gervois
et puis jabbari
tu peux pas vivre autant sur des tirs
trop complexe je pense que ça va être
travaillée par l'homme par le roster des
seules choses qui l'ont laissé jouer
comme il voulait un peu lui ont dit ok
tu un peu carte blanche offensivement il
s'est bien je trouve de faire ça on n'a
pas vraiment brider ou fait les choses
mais il a pris une tonne une tonne de
deux poulpes contesté qui rentrait par
mon nom à auburn l'an passé là ça c'est
pas trop en glisse et 5,12 défensivement
où il a fait un vrai chantier
défensivement c'est intéressant parce
qu'on avait un débat même dans l'équipe
est ce que c'est un joueur qui est ce
que c'est un super défenseur d'ailier ou
est ce que c'est un
futur post 5 alors est-ce qu'on a une
réponse plus claire
jeu avant j'avais un peu mis de côté le
post 5 je pense que il peut terminer des
matchs en poste 5 il peut finir il
pourra finir des matchs parce qu'à la
capacité de switch sur des plus petits à
l'activité
la protection de serre par contre je
pense que c'est bien si on lui met un
gros protecteur de serques secondaire à
côté lorsque garuba élus peuvent bien
s'entendre défensivement si jamais ça ça
marche donc serge dugas robin et qu'eva
tu m'enlèves les mondes labellisé plex
et lavelanet regard ou moi non mais là
il a végété angélique pas mal alors que
l'équipe ne jouait rien non plus donc on
verra mais mes jupes tort je suis
rassuré sur l'aspect l'aspect défensif
sur le post aux siens que john barry
smith mais sur l'activité la polyvalence
on savait en pause et des chaînes x chef
christopher ce ne serait ce pas là de
deux joueurs qui peuvent faire une
carrière honnête d'arrière qui sortent
du bon
l'amp sa déférence l'autre portion les
costaudes et chez nyx moi j'aimais bien
de chez nous il est vraiment costaud et
elle est toujours aussi costaud bourg
passeur dépasse à ce marché un peu
dessus avec avec taye taiwo qui donnent
ce qu'ils avaient la création et tout ça
parce que des jeunes à fait trouvé selon
ce que ce que disaient les fans des
roquettes selebi 3 est un très gros
bonne année de gigue en fête l'an
dernier ou plus le coach un des coaches
de houston c'était le coach j league
l'an dernier qui ensuite va l'essonne un
staff des roquettes cette année donc il
connaissait très bien des phénix
christopher c1 ce ne sera pas le lui
trace croire qu'on avait au lycée que
manu adorait par exemple mais ça va être
un vrai besoin d'une rotation je pense
le tir est toujours un peu bizarre en
deux temps mais c'est un athlète moi
donc je pense après midi il va compter
dans le projet roquettes je pense et des
phoenix ouais a toujours intéressant
grâce à il a développé un peu d un tout
petit peu son jumper
problème principal costaud carré et non
pas sur quoi c'est ça dès demain tous a
une bonne technique
à la passe nous allons parler des
français
mais avant
attendez je suis en train de retrouver
mon programme avant on va parler de
détroit
ben on a vu un match et 100 minutes
j'ai donné absolument est ce que c'est a
suffi pour être satisfaits et pour
envisager la manière dont il a joué
quand la saison reprendra est ce que ce
sera dans ce rôle là exactement de gros
porteur de ballon
je crois pas dans ce rôle de gros
porteur de ballon parce que je crois
qu'il vaut vraiment partagé le monde
avec qui elle connaît bien mais quelques
années gamme est un peu déjà l'alpha la
bosse à dire
que toute la défense or
organisé va s'ancrer dans les machines
billets donc on va demander à jean de
nay vit normalement de tirer les boules
on va demander à john a envie de jouer
au ballon je crois qu'ils sont là mais
on n'a jamais entendu dans le processus
d'entrevue qui avaient dit qu'ils
étaient très à l'aise avec ça surtout
justement s'ils jouent aux dés dans le
créateur comme il veut
donc non seuil était très impressionnant
pour longtemps qu'on le budget de ma vie
mais maintenant je crois je te vois
qu'on le placer dans un roe de carte
blanche
ça a bien fonctionné
un mois sur les tirs à l'impression
qu'on puisse y a pas à l'extrême comme
si les analyses mais qu'il a un peu ce
truc deux
à trois points en tout cas ils aiment
bien se le créer plus que du catch and
shoot donc si ce n'était pas le cas sur
les stades
mais on avait vu a perdu quand même l'an
dernier que dans les trois plans en
mouvement sur catherine souty s'était
améliorée et si ça va être vraiment
vraiment important pour lui puisque caïd
aura le ballon mais est donc il y aura
des décalages qui seront faits de l'île
soit prêt devra prendre une décision sur
le cir soit attaqué le cercle je pense
qu'il n'attaquera pas mal le cercle
parce que moi ce que je retiens c'est
qu'il est le contexte mais relègue les
cinq cartes en personne pourrait être
stoppée pour aller au cirque franchement
il était la pression sur les serbes qui
manquaient d'ailleurs qui manque au jeu
de qui tenir comme way est apportée par
des nervis la complémentarité en effet
extrêmement sens on avait des passants
transition aussi des espèces de lecture
j'ai vu que ça pouvait être un joueur
extrêmement fort en transition pour
pousser la balle
donc
le tyran spots up sera vraiment la cause
de progression sur les premières années
parce que dans le reste la
complémentarité fait vraiment son site
web moi je joue à droite ça d'un mauvais
oeil le fait que je te voyais que se
crée son tir lui-même parce que
justement lorsqu'on va arriver dans des
situations ce qui me rend plus de
pression sur lui il va être capable de
descendre et
comme ça ça doit faire partie du du de
l'arsenal d'un shooter des lidd c'est
juste qu'il faut pas qu'ils tombent en
amour avec sa propre création parce que
la partie difficile il donne
en tout cas de ce qu'on a vu il mérite
elle l'étiquette de style en
choix numéro 5
galen du reste a été le choix numéro 13
je m'en remets pas
ben est ce que tu veux parler
d'utilisation jahren dow
jones qui était clair c'est qu'il ya
besoin d'un créateur il ya besoin de
quelqu'un pour lui m les mettre le
ballon dans les mains quelqu'un qui
comprend comment servir de lui aussi
avec jaden avis il était très grand et
je crois que ces deux joueurs qui sont
extrêmement complémentaires mais écoutez
on a vu physiquement par un non
seulement il est haut niveau mais il a
le niveau plus plus je crois pour être
le pivot dominant albi maintenant est ce
que c'est un pivot qui va être
uniquement un repreneur ou celui de
pivot pour être capable de développer
certains moi j'ai pas été convaincue qu'
il va être capable d'atteindre ce niveau
là mais six sessions 6 g john deere en
devient un brownie brown
s'est écrit à toutes sortes d'effectifs
donc moi j'ai été impressionné par ce
que j'ai vu mais j'ai pas j'ai peur il
m'a pas montré quelque chose à
l'extérieur que le paradigme comme on
m'avait rien dit
peut-être un peu défensivement à l'année
où il a quand même assez rassuré sur ses
attitudes en général
moi je serais pas positivement surpris
mais très très content de ce que j'ai vu
comme la c1 c'est un internat cration
d'extérieur et on s'est mariés qui est
toujours compliqué pour moi ce jour là
il va lui parce que ont pas mal de gars
jobs pour leur pomme ou s'est passé chez
le mât très simples qui sont mis en
place ou en ces tests et steve jones
dans une pop casillas duncan keith a été
coach en j-league way cas coaching
d'en-cas coaching un coach et va se
marier avec les grises et je crois qu'il
disait en gros là trois jeux quoi il ya
un pick and go sur un pick and roll
tiger potentiellement que ce concert est
à pas grand-chose pour durer non n'a pas
pu voir bas cela on a pu voir un petit
peu les passes on n'a pas pu voir
vraiment cette décision sur short royal
pains spéciaux de fou quand il a joué
comme il ya des joueurs qui jouent un
peu pour eux je pense qu'avec quelques
une gamme avec des données vie avec
kylie annexe ii s'il n'a pas beaucoup
j'écris analyse malheureusement ça va ça
va l'aider moi j'étais rassuré sur la
physicalité
c'est ccsa quart d'entre eux en nba avec
le facteur x ne l'a pas assez du tir
qu'on a vu on n'a pas trop vu non plus
les jeunes
déjà il est légitime à jouer je pense
entre 10 et 15 minutes l'an prochain
déjà bien il a passé beaucoup de son
temps depuis 100 jours un truc
d'ailleurs le savez peut-être un peu
plus sans y a pas de tant de monde
prestation
stewart a commencé à prendre les trois
points de partout à semer rowling et
j'étais déjà je suis tu es déjà oui ça
arrive il ne faisait pas tout et me fait
plaisir il ya lisons l'inique aussi je
crois on sait pas s'ils ont fait reculer
ils ont aussi marvin blake a une super
entente à rabais
avec kate donc il va jouer il va jouer
oui ils sont pas montés fonds de loterie
pour le désagrément c'est
un projet effectivement pour les pistols
alan boston et ce qui est ce qu'on
retient quelque chose avant parler pour
lui spécifiquement de jeunes bégard
franchement c'était cette élite va mal
soit le roster pas incroyable quand tu
devras fois au premier tour trois années
de suite aux essais et donc que tu as
plus en plus que tu veux que plus
nesmith n'est plus là elle pas grant a
pas grand prospère a observé c'était un
peu c'est un petit peu autour de djezzy
davison qui s'est fait draft et tafer
café des cafés des chiffres en tant que
porteur de balle principal ce qui
n'était pas trop alabama alabama il
sortait du monde et les queens et rallye
il y avait chez que le ford y avait et
lisse là on avait en bas courte davison
dégâts des shooteurs donc ça mother
l'ancien de virginie qu'à signer un
contrat matt ryan qui a été excellent
aussi qui jouait à 24 bild je sais pas
si vous vous souvenez il joua van der
veer juin notre dame aussi ont le droit
d'être moi je te refais erbil et je veux
pas tennessee de chattanooga sait il a
fait trois fois que mais si les gens
savent écouter ci-dessus est un gars là
franchement je
n'ai fait les trois il a été très bon
mais n'a pas été signé parce que le tout
et a été donnée à davison et à kabengele
donc fusion du kabengelé ans un genre
florida state drafté en 2019 ouais 2019
au premier tour avec keepers qui était
très très
bruts en sortie de florida state et
qu'il a
un profil de raymond runner qui attire à
3 points donc c'est intéressant du côté
de boston davison très très bon presque
très bonne pression vers le cercle ce
qu'on voyait à la maman peut-être que il
révèle compatible avec sûrement plus de
talent et potentiels que les drafté en
32e course jusque est ce qu'ils vont
préférer peut-être des genres tu aurais
dit puisqu'il est pas prêt à jouer en
nba mais je pense est un bon projet pour
la g-league des décennies c'est un wagon
projets des jeunes il mais d'après ce
qu'un cercle et talentueux donc il a
rentré ses tirs c'était des tirs faciles
à résoudre les équipes adverses avec
begarin qui n'a donc pas eu le guen je
sais pas si le viser ou pas
eurostar c'est compliqué parce que on
kabengele qui prend le tout et ça veut
dire
c'est peut-être juste une assurance à
l'intérieur parce qu'ils n'ont pas non
plus une profondeur de ouf à l'intérieur
je sais peut-être une assurance pour
boston
c'est ça ce qu'il dit c'est quoi ça nous
vacciner 1 1 85e intérieur il ya
williams orford cornette et kabengele
pour l'instant c'est pas incroyable
entre les ordures et des daniel thijs
pour redonner aux prague d'année
dernière 10 je vois un rôle quand même
accessoirement accessoires mais très
importante
surtout de la saison régulière qu'en
venant de celui du genre moi j'étais
très très agréablement surpris par un
national de béghin honnêtement je trouve
que cette année il avait parfois un peu
plafonné en betclic on avait été le voir
plusieurs fois j'ai cru y avoir
plusieurs fois à la halle carpentier 4,5
fois en tout en fait le jeu et le jeu
nba mais si c'est pas de l'envié le jeu
et aux états unis ça colle beaucoup plus
à ses qualités
parce que c'est du jeu c'est du jeu
rapide il a pris quelques décisions
vraiment le dribble s'est améliorée le
tir reste la lande question parce que le
tir ne vient jamais ça pourrait
peut-être devenir ce genre de bruce
brown jr east high tone parce qu'il ya
des fermes athlétique le rôle que tu
aimes bien dont on essaie de trouver des
joueurs dans la dernière heure après à
voir ce qui va se passer c'est vrai que
c'est assez délicat parce que les boston
a perdu beaucoup en profondeur donc ce
qu'ils vont plutôt chercher à des
joueurs pour faire le nombre même temps
un jour comme madar est toujours en
europe a été drafté et a été 7 h et là
bas mais avec des changements de rôle
vous faites il ya commencé les restes en
israël ensuite il est passé aux
partisans en eurocup cette année ait aux
partisans en euroligue donc il ya un
changement d'étape ce que l'état parce
que l'approché table pour pékin c'est un
changement d'étape en europe
c'est-à-dire par rivages où paris va
jouer l'europe l'an prochain mais ce que
ça va être avec paris ou est ce que
c'est la ji je sais pas c'est un athlète
g-league en tout cas mais il reste chez
nous il est jeune c'est un 2002 donc
peut-être après je sais pas mais je suis
assez satisfait ce que j'ai vu plus que
l'an dernier quoique l'autre belle
satisfaction côté français c'est la
semaine reliques de moussa diabaté
même si lui aussi sans doute aura peu de
temps de jeu cette année mais ça diabaté
il a été il a montré ce qu'ils savaient
faire et il a et il a été mis dans les
conditions pour pas trop montré ses
limites aussi ça dans une bonne équipe
de mercenaires parce que jay scrub biya
boston il n'était pas venu pour
pour
autre chose que faire des stades de bons
joueurs le plaisir de revoir une chaise
scrub
le gaucher heureusement il a eu jason
preston en fait ça a été qu'il a bien
servi on a vu voit la polyvalence de
moussa diabaté deuxième rideau finition
au cercle nrj nrj nrj il a un moment ils
meyrin je crois que c'est le premier
match qui fait contre memphis il fait un
spin move dunk à demain steve ballmer
sur le côté qui se lève
assez assez assez à fond donc la bonne
satisfaction je pense que je pense que
c'est le gimmick pour lui à fond et
développement avec les aqua caliente
clippers exactement il a rentré un trois
points dans le corner ce qui sera peut
être
de bon augure pour lui pour cette année
de
j-league en français il nous reste hugo
besson nous a demandé pourquoi il jouait
pas moi on ne sait pas on n'était pas là
bas y semant nouveau besson n'a pas joué
il va jouer au metropolitan cela
l'avenir ça
j'ai pas de ces signes ou de
célébrations nationales
il faut une équipe de prospects et
il sema compliqué aussi un athée c'est
compliqué d'être drafté au second tour
dans des équipes qui jouent en fait le
titre foster's qui il co signe jordan
ambac pourquoi
en voyant de
parler mais qu'il a vu mais
ouais non mais non mais je crois que
kamagaté méritait ce spot led je pense
qu'ils ont montré qu'ils étaient
capables de faire les choses que dit
andré jordan fait encore mieux avec plus
d'explosivité puis je crois qu'il est et
il est désigné pour ce mystique talent
d'un vestiaire d'être des terrains est
pour moi un gain qui se fait de nos
contrats cadeau de 80 40 millions par
kid keven durette et
qui est karine je pense qu'on peut
revoir son sens des priorités non
kamagaté pour moi une
[Musique]
mauvaise chute en déclin lui il aime le
dire le mauvais goût de vivre pourtant
les collines gillespie là plutôt mis en
avant sur certains passages
il fait une super ça me dit qu'il ya
plein de super league c'est juste que il
s'est ramassé derrière un vétéran une
comme une commodité que les équipes nba
connaissent oui mais c'est presque
étonnant
c'est qu'il a même pas le tout est
à revoir et à nous tout est alors
souvent ça veut dire peut-être que s'il
n'y a pas d'abandon de projets mais on
ne veut pas tout de suite c'est à dire
peut-être qu'ils veulent le faire
saillir encore breiz un an de geely
ghost h voilà peut-être après si tu
prends quand même un risque
contractuelle de peut-être te le faire
piquer sindjelic pris seulement mais ça
que jack white récupère le thouet ça va
assez surpris l'australien
a pas le même niveau de joueur sans
faire injure à jack white est-ce que
vous avez des and just et de stand out
vas-y belle
mon gars m'ont flingueurs sans âme de
préférer l'année dernière où
les deux golfeurs qui était possédée par
ledit par le fantôme de john smit à
l'assemblée qui lançait des patates
absolument n'importe où et ça rentre ça
rentrait jusqu'à un certain point parce
qu'ils étaient avec des playmaker il y
avait des bons il y avait des bons tirs
on lui donnait des pompiers et je pense
qu'un gars qui qu'une confiance en
lui-même qu'une confiance en sortir
comme ça a une place à une bible
à quelques pas surtout dans une équipe
comme nous qui s'y qui joue encore une
fois cette année rien en particulier
mais qui va avoir beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de playmaker sur le terrain
ils ont moi j'adore et aux caisses ils
ont mis le joueur dans le roster
des
loyers mais ceux-ci il ay lorsqu'ils
cèdent chacun followill équipe qui on
peut acheter n'importe et où le tibet
libre roulé sa bosse en nba il va faire
bien tu m'as danse beaucoup plus de
matos qu'ils auraient dû mais je
m'ennuyais un peu du rôle de flingueur
sans oblige
c'est vrai et en plus c'est un joueur
qui est quand même assez dense
physiquement
capable de tenir le choc sur qui
défendent un tout petit peu plus grand
que sa taille parce qu'il est plein
c'est carrément tasse à l'année
alors est-ce qu'on a droit des noms
rookie wes jallet des besoins des hommes
sans la paroisse bois tu penses que tu
peux c'est un peu de cachet et de gel au
sol et des semaines il a fait une super
salle le canadien d'ailleurs qui a été
signé un contrat signé un contrat après
cette ce mardi je crois qu'il a la laddh
a joué avec wes et ça c'est ça il est
des mémoires il a signé avec une autre
équipe que dacia signé avec minnesota je
crois si je me rappelle bien
il foutait super bien en fait donc
mettez trois la moitié de ces trois
points alors qu'il en prenait 5 par mois
que sur la summer league c'était le
canadien qu'on avait vu à south carolina
on avait tous abandonné il était arrivé
avec une belle taille pour un dossier on
avait tous abandonné petit à petit et ça
c'est beau
c'est non full hipster in jura pour une
bille m et tommy kus de orlando je n'y
avais déjà 24 ans cousine oui cousy qui
joua centre mais oui c'est le show ouais
la bourgeoisie et qu'elle était trop
fort dans la seconde étude allait il a
été trop fort les trois ans tout ce que
tu vois c'est ça il est inutile je
regarde 17 points de moyenne 4 passes
décisives
ira pas je sais pas aussi si vous avez
regardé un peu de new york les gammes et
fernand h1n1 sur la chaîne us rémy ou
rouge qui faisait elle le roleplay la
direction junior de foncer vers le
panier finir d d aller où et peut-être
une piste défensivement où est ce qu'il
a été un
il a été hyper efficace parce qu' un
masque sept vols de balle il est déjà à
tous et avec new york ça m'étonnerait
pas qu'il soit qu'ils soient
transférés dans l'effectif donc un
créneau quelque chose du genre aucun tri
pour
donovan mitchell ou quelqu'une bourse
change pas c'est un joueur de rotation
éventuellement à quelque part beaucoup
de gros athlétique pour être cette faute
des bijoux à l'intérieur de ses moyens
et oui peut-être qu'il va profiter du
fait que new york près tous ces jeunes à
utah pour pour faire partie de
l'effectif possible ajournez an dernier
adonis armes qui a joué avec denver qui
joua texas tech alors qu'elle verra aux
figues séchées texas tech athlétique
texas tech hyper athlétique 3,4
je fais ça tu as exactement mon nom que
tu me le dis mais il a été utilisé comme
mes fonds utilise
other d'écran roulé fort finir il est et
je pense que ma vraie tally m'a
tellement plu que je pense qu'il va être
bon jean donc peut-être nom à retenir
adonis
j'en ai ingénieurs ou drafter de cette
année je laime de jeu depuis longtemps
parce que je suis hewson depuis
longtemps mais disent moi je n'ai pas vu
beaucoup j'ai vu un match de brooklyn
mais thèse mois à brooklyn il sait que
je suis un joueur de masques à dissipe
tout faire sur un terrain ici on peut
être une espèce de connecteurs de google
qui va apporter qu'est-ce qui manque ou
n'importe quel line up à ce qui va
rendre un peu plus de défense va être
capable d'en donner un peu plus il n'y a
pas de passer le ballon il est capable
de finir au panier le test un peu juste
un peu
en chantier encore mais on parle de
gueule moi qui joue à l'intérieur de ses
moyens
je me pose la question pour tous ces
joueurs là généralement c'est la carte
de visite c'est des bons joueurs de
basketball mais quelle quelle est ta
carte de visite pour quoi en quoi tu es
meilleur que
99 sont des autres joueurs il a justifié
que
dans le cas de deux mois c'est
intéressant parce que j'en vois une on a
lyon ils ont laissé brooklyn bruce brown
quitté sans même lui offrir deux contres
je crois qu'on peut lui demander joué de
façon similaire il n'est peut-être pas
aussi rapide donc que que bruce bras je
crois qu'il est capable d'aller jouer
dans le trafic il est très épais il est
très forte des écrans en plus demandés a
joué dans traffic jam de face et qu'à
l'inversé il sera pas je crois aussi
efficace que bruce bon du moins bon et
efficace immédiatement mais c'est
peut-être une des raisons pour
lesquelles ont
soumis kusile ainsi
tommy cousy à matt ryan matt ryan
dernière buzzer beater on se tordant la
cheville bien sûr contenu et camille 6
ou 7 3 points sur deux des matches mais
ça reste un goût qui l'a 25 ans mais
c'est un exemple notre dame on forme des
joueurs exactement uniquement
favorable et course et dans l'épisode 2
on parlera de paolo banque quéro deutsch
est une graine de john williams
bénédicte marine merci à vous de nous
avoir écoutés merci à la merci ben ça
ton reste efforts buvez hydratez vous et
à bientôt
[Musique]